As we saw with the OpenStreetMap data,
XML tags often contain attribute name value pairs.
One example of attributes in this data set
is the iid attribute of this institutional relationship
tag, or insr tag. The iid value here
actually defines a relationship between an author and
institutions with which they are affiliated. Institutions appear
later in this institution group, here, as individual
elements of their own. Now in the last
exercise we ignored these insr tags. Let's address
them here. We're going to update our solution
to the last exercise to use the data
in these insr tags. See the code I've
provided. However, rather than an insr field in
your author dictionaries, store an iid field for
each author. Note that some authors will have
multiple insr tags. The value for the iid field then for
authors needs to be an array composed of all the iids for a given author. For
each author, create an iid field. Note
that some authors are actually affiliated with
multiple institutions, so the value for your iid fields needs to be an array.